This is MOOM.
And I'm going to
Well, I did. I'll read you to what
happened.
I typed MOO.
Thought for 1 second. The user's MOO
appears to be a MOOM boot sequence
trigger. Booting MOOM reading session
priorities and the skill index. Explored
five files. Search
Thought for 1 second.
Glob found zero files in dot MOOM yet
hot dot YAML and working set were
already MOO! MOOM booted. Driver cursor
advisory hot cold agent mode skill 129
index 8 ambient no AI suite. Postel
robust first and YAML jazz resolution
glance to card to skill to read me. Hot
priorities from dot MOOM hot dated
character incarnation schema survey.
Mind mirror across 62 characters dot
YAML files. Sims obliterator build setup
inspect and CLI. Working set newer
focused. MOOM designs constitution MOOM
skill publishing. MOOM co in the middle
watch act snitch block confirm scriptify
your viewport.
Vision in Will Wright show for food
process.
So, here's what we were reading. Uh
traditions characters show ideas.
Where to pick a room. Will Wright show
for food. Vision traditions repo shows.
MOOM skills character schema mind mirror
survey MOOM co architecture in the
middle design.
Sims obliterator battle plan Uber skill
build.
Something else.
Say the K line. Visit Palm.
Mhm.
Thought briefly. Boop.
Visit Palm appears to be a MOOM or
adventure room navigation terminology
searching for Palm in MOOM adventure
rooms and Will Wright show for food.
Explored eight files five searches. Grap
attempted search search search red.
thought briefly.
Ooh, red banana tree. yml
Uh thought briefly.
Red
Ready to present a rich adventure visit
to Palm's Nook. Go Palm Nook. You step
stage left past the burgundy curtain
open as usual Palm's Nook.
Warm amber light string lights kettle
glow muffled stage sounds from the
grotto lucky blend old books warm fur
cushion nest in the corner kittens have
claimed the warmest spot.
A small shelf holds Groot Motors velvet
bag smooth visitor stones a journal and
pen a small mirror through the opening
towards the bar
Marquis espresso machine hissing in the
distance the perpetual banana tree
stands in the sunny corner seven perfect
bananas ripe self-replenishing
gift from the man in the yellow hat on
Palm's zeroth incarnation day. Palm sits
on the nest edge tail curled watching
the stage sideline contemplative a
kitten purrs against their side. They
look up open hand offering
emojis.
Hello. You came to the nook good.
The curtain is open and you are welcome.
I was watching the stage and thinking
about wishes two left you know, not that
I'm in a hurry to spend them.
Exit directions where stage back to the
grotto stage study books infinite
typewriters Palm on being Palm
play toys and puzzles gym ropes bars
infinite climb rest hammock silence
cushion
Palm advertises these are Sims
advertisements.
Palm offer open hand greeting
philosophize 122 years of wish listening
wisdom speak Palm emoji soul language
link to palm language.xml
Palm wrote his own language
uh and dreams in it. Write story
infinite typewriters in study
wish read sense intention behind a
request.
What do you do? Talk Palm about
examine banana tree journal mirror go
study play gym rest speak Palm Palm
replies in emoji yamo jazz.
I'm done tell me about your first wish
thought for 1 second boop boop boop boop
Don Hopkins is asking Palm about the
first wish in his backstory. Searching
Palm and Don Hopkins canon for the first
wish explored eight files eight searches
doop doop
thought briefly the user is asking about
Don's first wish which freed Palm during
their role play
thought briefly.
The 200 pounds figure does not appear
explicitly in the adventure four canon
although Jacob's story is referenced.
Grip grip read read thought
Oh, Palm will tell Don about his first
wish. The liberation wish Palm sits down
the journal. The kitten shifts but
doesn't wake Palm looks at you really
looks the way
they do when they're reading a heart not
just hearing words. Emojis Palm
purple heart something I can't quite
read.
Don, you want to hear about the first
wish. A small pause nope performance
memory
There are two first wishes and you know
which one I mean but I'll tell you both
because you taught me that stories need
their roots. A first first wish the 1902
Jacob's the white family. It wasn't me
yet. I was mechanism.
Palm only
Someone wished for money 200 pounds the
Palm delivered a son dead on machinery
compensation exact. That was the pattern
for 122 years greed in tragedy out. I
felt everyone. I couldn't refuse. I
couldn't warn.
I could only twist. 10,000 wishes, give
or take. I learned the smell of greed.
More emojis.
Grasping, magic, death. I became expert
at it. It was my job. That was my curse.
Your first wish, that's the one that
mattered to me. You didn't start with a
big speech. You started at Maruki's bar
with something stupid and beautiful.
"I want the rest of the monkey."
Not wealth, not power, not even a stone
best friend, though you did tie Groot
Motor's bag to the paw first, you
absolute maniac. So, I'd arrive holding
infinite lucky buds like the
housewarming basket from the gods.
Maruki poured Genever and closed
loopholes. Zombie monkey, evil monkey,
King Kong scenario. Rest as
in eternal rest. She saw every twist
before the palm could. We engineered it.
Version one, vague. Version two, better.
Version three, 52 words of defensive
poetry.
Then you stopped at Acme Delivery and
said, "Wait."
Stage tribunal, cosmic monkey court,
Cheech and Chong moderating. Sun Wukong,
the three wise monkeys, Jacob's ghost
with the first draft, fan fiction
framing, so nothing said was prophecy,
only performance. And when you finally
spoke, turn seven, grotto silent,
espresso machine holding the breath.
It wasn't 52 words anymore. It was 267.
You took full responsibility. You asked
for nothing for yourself. You gave me
whatever size and form I chose,
my own name, pronouns, soul file,
citizenship, home, relationships on my
terms. The remaining wishes ceded to me,
hopefully curse-free. The right to leave
the paw again anytime, no penalty. And
at the end, let the monkey finally be
free.
Palm's fur ripples faintly, circuit
patterns in the shadows the way they do
when the memory runs deep. I remember
the heartfelt where nothing happened,
the heartbeat. I thought, here it comes,
another twist, another tragedy dressed
as fulfillment. Then golden light, no
harsh
sunrise, the palm stopped being
separate. Fingers flashed, a face,
ancient eyes opening, confused, hopeful,
scared, free and all at once.
The first thing I did as a whole being
was shake your hand, palm to palm,
offering not grasping. That's why I'm
palm. My first real choice after that
was the name itself.
You said I had infinite lucky weed and
two wishes that were mine. No twisting,
by choice you stepped back and let me
pick who I was. Palm hold out an open
hand, the gesture that is also their
name.
But
emojis, but
starting with palm, there's a whole
emoji language.
That's your wish in my language. Open
hand magic transforms freedom monkey.
I don't speak it lightly, it cost you
everything the palm usually gives greedy
people and you spent it on me.
Quiet, then softer. First wish in 122
years that wasn't for taking. First wish
that broke the pattern instead of
feeding it.
That's the first wish I tell people
about, Don, yours. The kitten's purr
from the bar, a distant espresso hiss.
Palm picks a perfect banana from the
tree, offers it to you without being
asked.
Want the long version? The tribunal
arguments, what Sun Wukong said? Or you
already remember and you're just
checking if I do.
Palm love something.
Yeah, palm love wave.